what's up hey what up hey Carly how are
you this is the show it's got what the
lifestyle yeah and this is our friend
yeah
finally we're here here we are and so
excited to be here with you I mean
finally Ivan wanted to be on the show
forever
what is your debut today we chose you
because we know you have good taste
first class thank you and we're looking
at houses yes but not just any houses
and we are bringing and real Nick II
producer of the shoot
I love Andrew he's up there today I'm
worth it lifestyle we're gonna be
checking out to different tiny houses
have to drastically different price
points to find out which one is the most
worth it as price I'm just happy to be
here I'm happy to go look at some tiny
homes I'm born and raised in LA and
Hollywood the real estate has gone up so
much yeah I can't live in my own
neighborhood which makes these like
small houses like fascinating to me the
first tiny house it's up in Ventura and
it's called humble handcraft
I mean it's all in the words its humble
and it's handcrafted I'm Ryan O'Donnell
I own and operate humble handcraft
we are gonna check out my personal home
the Acorn it really sounds fun that's a
good name yeah it's this tiny as an
acorn pretty much so how did you get
your start into building tiny homes I
was working as a carpenter on big custom
homes and there was a lot of waste so I
wanted to build something small more
reclaimed materials do you mind defining
what a tiny home is tiny home to me is
something that you can move I'd say
probably you're under 500 square feet
people can actually own their space take
it where they want at a much more
affordable price you describe the
interior of the Acorn to me you walk
through the back end of the trailer
which is the front door you look to the
right there's a kitchen counter there's
a sleeping loft there's a lower hangout
with an entertainment room can you cook
in there and it's got a stove oven I'll
be using there's a shower Wow
we're trying to represent the green
movement and if we can build these
things completely without the man's help
I think that says a lot just learn right
who's the man
I don't know I'm still trying to find
him what are the prices like would he
send you home typically they started
around 50 and go up as high as 200 it
were it's just ended up yeah what kind
of systems we install what kind of
materials we use how much does a bond
cost the Acorn itself was 50 grand we
are here we wrap acorn the Acorn why
does any acorn Rienzi born
it feels very magical come here get your
spell's in here would you like me to
find you a girlfriend I'll cast the
spell totally in the Acorn it kind of
looks like a giant bird you know and if
I was a bird I would want to live here
remove those shoes I like it we might be
here for another half hour
yes oh wow you know the fine line
between a good hug and strangling yeah I
was not sure where it was gonna land but
this is a warm hug where I feel like I
could live here weirdly I've been in
many kitchens that are bigger but still
feel smaller my kitchen is definitely
bigger than this that this has more
counter by the sink looks awesome that
think is amazing yeah like a perfect
bathtub for a baby I want to see what he
eat this is the fridge yeah that's more
than what's in my fridge right now you
know check of the shower that's a very
important okay I'm 6 feet tall and I'm
totally in I want to be 60 tough but if
you look right down the drain that goes
right down to the soil I always think
like I'm not wasting water that wasn't
go yeah do something so your bathroom
you by the way or just the bathroom
there's a bathroom in the back to the
entertainment center okay this is the do
short a little bit short here's a little
TV in here look here's books you have
enough space with your clothes can
entertain you can get this little guitar
your sibling yes you ever build like
blanket forts yeah oh yeah that's what I
was thinking like this is kind of like
the ultimate kid imagination space I
would have moments when I was younger
where all I wanted to do was just chill
watch a movie eat and then take a nap
wake up to watch a movie and yeah and
this is like the perfect combo because
everything is so close you could roll
from your bed to the oven
yep I'm back he has a fireplace having a
fireplace is a luxurious thing I have
announced the introvert in me is loving
yeah it's not even just cozy it's
comfortable
so it's like an introverts dream come
true everything sounds like you're
really trying to flirt with me at least
once I got this shot he mentioned that
he's working on a ladder as of right now
uh-huh but that he uses the counter to
jump up onto the bed
oh so down for that part a little
worried about Dean X I feel a little
gassy it in my gut oh good help it's
scary for me I'm like oh man I gotta go
back down there actually that would be a
deterrent to getting out of bed you
gotta climb down now what do you get
creative like this is where all the
magic happens here but that's not the
magic you can customize and you got your
own fireplace and it's like oh yeah it's
a lot bigger than I thought you can have
everything that you need in life as a
human being and not cause such a strain
on the earth I think it's cute I think
it's cozy I I don't think it's to be
called tiny home should be called cozy
Oh cozy home park or you know that
actually made me feel like maybe I could
live in one I mean I definitely am not
100% convinced but I wouldn't be mad but
are you a high- person or a load - I'm
super super chill but I also feel like a
lot of my own upbringing has always been
like yes you made it when you have like
an island in the kitchen preach away
please
yeah so according to a recent poll by
the National Association of Homebuilders
sixty-three percent of Millennials said
they would consider buying a tiny home
less than six hundred square feet Wow
okay first of all you should just be our
give in fact deliver you a very good
voice sidebar I want to know which
Millennials they're talking to you
because I'm like
604 feet is a lot of room actually in
New York City so before we go to our
last stop curly we're gonna go talk to
some people who live full-time in a tiny
home so how interested the feed how they
do how they do yeah I'm Julie Aikens
founder of vehicles for changes and we
are in our first buses in Ashland Oregon
and why are we in a bus we are in a bus
because we turn buses into homes for
homeless children and families he tell
us about your company and just how did
it all get started I was a journalist
and my project was to interview homeless
people and see how they became homeless
and how they live along that track I met
a bunch of families which I didn't
really think was out there I didn't know
there were a bunch of little kids
sleeping in cars and homeless in Oregon
there are 24,000 kids who don't have a
place to sleep at night it's
heartbreaking but sometimes I feel lost
I don't know what to do but that
situation or even how to help so how did
you then turn that idea into something
that's tangible and that actually able
to help people I literally had a dream
where I pictured a school bus with these
pretty window boxes with flowers and I
just was like could that happen
and through that process I discovered
schoolies so a school II is a school bus
that's been converted into a home and
then I wrote a blog about it with my
aspiration I would love to make a home
for homeless children and families out
of a school bus the very next day I got
an email from a woman I had never met
who said she would fund me for five
years to make buses Wow and then I went
into panic mode and what I have to do it
Wow all from a dream
I met Cody who builds these beautiful
homes like pretty much by himself and
then money comes in and then you can
build more houses so how many have you
created so far we named our buses the
first one was Betsy this is Mathilda and
our next one is Alexis do they already
have families that they're going to
create first and then we have an
application process for folks the way it
works is they move into the bus they
live in it for one year as a tenant with
there's no rent and then if they love
bus life we create a buyer's program and
they can buy a bus and then that's
and they own their home and they're good
to go so now we're gonna go meet a
family who lives in one it's the flood
family David Jennifer raly David jr. and
little Noah and now they live in now
they live in Betsy the Wonder Bus
people need a space that's secure and
warm and kind to them has to be home has
to be home right exactly
these are not for sale no they're not
for sale these are made specifically for
homeless families well thank you so much
right now that's near home you're
welcome thank you for coming there's a
lot of school buses out there but the
ones that Julie Aikens and Leo have done
is amazing I think on the outside but
when you come in it opens up let's go
look at the kitchen
private key just a little about what's
going on here yeah whoa okay
stove top we've got the microwave we've
got the cabinet there's a lot of
craftsmanship that went into making this
kitchen do you ever use a stove here
okay
I don't be I turn on a stove until I was
like 18 a lot of windows yes later and
one criteria for kitchen mmm when I look
at it does it inspire me to cook mm-hmm
this one does yes yeah
private really why don't you guys tell
us about where we are here this is my
sister's bunk do you guys share the
closet yeah we all share basically the
clouds are really beautiful up there you
painted them we've got the storage under
the beds oh wow thank you for letting us
hang out in your room we're now in our
bedroom mmm the master tell us a little
about what we have here it's nice it's
got a very big mattress there's a lot of
storage room under it took a little
sleep over a summer party always a
whimsical we definitely look at it that
way the door opens so you can put stuff
under this in there too oh wow I get
better than the flush toilet I thought
this kind of amazing that they put a
shower in here is good not just wow I
grew up with the tile shower so this
kind of made me feel good yeah
were less enough to get this you come
all the way in and it's like the safe
space this is the cubby hole yeah we're
the safe space down yes we have now
circled back to the living room area the
very front well the whole family's here
beautiful this was done by a local
artist we were camping at the rogue
State Park quite a bit during the summer
this looks exactly like a tree that was
out there as if it was kind of telling
us what was gonna happen is it
functional is the boss even living here
for is it how many months how has that
experience been it's spacious
compared to what we were living in
before so yeah I'm deeply grateful thank
you again so much for having us your
home
yeah thank you so much it's really nice
to meet all of you the kids are
brilliant thanks Noah thanks Noah you're
the star of the show now we're done take
our job here we go the final spot it's
company called new frontier and you
think tiny homes can't be luxurious well
you thought wrong girlie it sounds fancy
already I like it
my name is David Latimer I am the CEO
and founder of new frontier tiny homes
and today we're gonna look at the orchid
tiny home you tell me about how you got
started in I came across the tiny house
movement and it's just a confluence of a
lot of things I'm passionate about
design also the do-it-yourself ethos
sustainability in the Latour it's not
working a lot of my design inspiration
comes from Scandinavian design you've
got this cedar siding it's raised off of
the side but these are the siding carry
over in a perfect line all across the
roof I've got this cantilever deck and
it has a LED light that spans the entire
shape of the home the lighting in this
house was inspired by the solar eclipse
and it's the ultimate balanced light
means you don't see the source of the
lighting you've got this wall of glass
but that garage door opens up and it
gives you that extra living space have
some dreams how about a picnic but you
don't leave your living room right this
sofa is an actual full-size bed slides
out and then you've got a bunch of
storage in the actual benches so
custom-made walnut closet / covering of
the air conditioner and one really cool
thing is this house runs on solar so you
could like cook over here have guests
the over got a king-sized bed in the
wall king-size bed there's no way oh I
thought I can't fit since I've been in
my bedroom and it does bring out yeah
just that I feel like a child again like
the bougie tree huh exactly how much is
the organ if I were to purchase about
165 I under sixty five thousand
it's beautiful ok ok alright let's try
the oh ok Matt it is the Carroll son
that what is that how he sit yeah good
yeah and there's a bed underneath this
thing
whoa nice yeah this is comfy there's a
little bookshelf in here you want do you
want this pillow yeah you can like
Nestle so I'm just gonna is this for
your eyes so you can sleep you don't
know where that's been
what's cool about this tiny house is
that design with restrictions creates
the most beautiful thing I want this in
my normal me too you don't do that
because I'm like what can every
apartment is but I can put away why does
my part not have floor-to-ceiling I know
why don't I have a giant garage coming
this thing you really do feel like you
were in nature without having to
interact with the nature like I'm a cop
but I'm not about that bug lights let's
go on the kitchen let's go beautiful
steps there and now we're on the second
floor this is really cool it makes the
space feels so much bigger it does it
feels like little surprises like those
little dolls and you keep opening them
and oh yeah small bit but it's the
opposite okay so certainly somebody
couldn't be cooking while you're here or
I could just watch you sleep from here
you could use this as a desk I do a lot
a journal that's worthless my morning
today in my tiny home I sat at this tiny
desk that how I found in my journal I'm
gonna just pop this out what do you want
for breakfast curly eggs a book today
okay crack them eggs not bad flip flip
flip flip yeah open your mouth I don't
want to see if what the water would look
like oh that's a good that's a good one
hold on and you kind of have to put
everything away right away I feel like
yes you let this place get messy it's
like what are you doing but I want to go
check out the nothing because there's
super-important to me of course and I
know they're super important to you what
is that I did not expect this but I
guess that's the theme of tiny houses
every real estate hack throw a mirror in
there and the room gets twice as big so
you got two mirrors this toilet is huge
whoa
wow it looks futuristic drawer space hey
yo
okay obviously did a hair straightener
give her dinner no thanks up and this is
your hair this is my mother and the Lord
oh oh I hate that I keep saying this but
it's bigger than shower in a hot shower
you think tiny house you think like tiny
cooking yeah honey food yeah but it's
more like no hallways house yeah you
actually necessity house yeah although I
really love my hallway
what are you doing your hallway I
pretend I'm a runaway model i bash him
in my hallway that's what I know we're
gonna find a room the laughs let's go to
LA yeah and it goes here right
Wow look at that pause it though here it
is I don't know if that'll fit oh my but
it fits a ladder
let's go first this is a king-sized bed
definitely the funnest room like if you
and your significant other and you just
want to cuddle and you kind of want to
be alone from like your friends or
whatever like this is perfect you know
is your bedroom the punishment master
that you're home um yes ultimate
efficient use of space it is literally a
room with a bed my bedroom was actually
more of my sanctuary my safe space in my
own house warming party I ghosted it
it's just too much you know so I wonder
my bedroom close the door I know I know
rolling over oh it's fun that was fun
but also I'm alright for my life right
now
let's get the shoes back on one hour or
later
okay finally the dick oh there you go
whoo this is exactly the same space it's
like a regular apartment I love how we
just literally pop the wall open indoor
outdoor indoor/outdoor you wanna try it
[Laughter]
I'm gonna ask you a very difficult
question Oh tell me all the homes are
worth it they're practically a price
point yes but which tiny home was almost
worth it to you and it's given price I
think my city boy
bujji miss mm-hmm I think I would pick
new frontier
that's only come in a while I'm a fan of
space I'm a fan of open windows hey my
winner yeah so mine what's a winner
mm-hmm has to go to Humble Anchorage it
was just so homey and it just had that
nook you get away in and I just felt
like that was perfect for me as an
introvert to get away are very lovable
yeah and when you do have limited
amounts of space there are clever ways
to use it and make it really pretty and
beautiful it speaks to my New York soul
little space big heart we both know that
the real MVP of all of this is people's
for changes mm-hmm we need people like
her in this world I agree you see a
problem see you need and they're like
I'm gonna make it happen by just going
out and doing it Andrew who's your what
the winner you can't choose them this
how it works
okay all right chosen then just pan to
nothing
I'm gonna go home curly but through it
I'm afraid thanks for being the best
guest thank you for having me uh-huh
there was so much fun you're better
Andrew as a co-host thank you yeah burn
I'm just kidding